el examen de matemáticas de maría
incluye una encuesta preguntando cuántas
horas han pasado los estudiantes
estudiando para el examen la grafica
siguiente muestra una relación entre las
horas que los estudiantes estudiaron y
su calificación en el examen
mariah dibujo la siguiente línea para
mostrar la tendencia en los datos
asumiendo que la línea es correcta que
significa una pendiente de línea de 15
así que veamos el eje horizontal es el
tiempo de estudio en horas y el eje
vertical son las calificaciones en el
examen por lo que cada uno de estos
puntos azules representan el tiempo y la
calificación de los estudiantes entonces
este estudiante de aquí pasa no sé
digamos qué pasa
puntos seis horas estudiando no le fue
muy bien en el examen parece que obtuvo
menos de 45 un 43 o 44 en el examen
este estudiante de aquí pasó casi cuatro
horas y media estudiando y obtuvo parece
que obtuvo un 94 casi un 95 en el examen
y lo que hizo maría fue dibujar una
línea que intentara ajustar estos datos
parece que hace un trabajo bastante
bueno de obtener de por lo menos mostrar
la tendencia en los datos ahora una
pendiente de 15 significa que si estoy
en la línea digamos que estoy aquí y si
avanzo en la dirección horizontal una
unidad se avanzó en la dirección
horizontal uno debería de incrementar en
la dirección vertical en 15
y vemos eso si incrementamos una hora
aquí incrementamos un 15% en el examen
ahora lo que significa es que la
tendencia que muestra es que en general
a través de esta tendencia
si alguien estudia una hora extra y si
estamos yendo con esa tendencia entonces
es razonable que esperen ver una
ganancia del 15% en su examen ahora
veamos cuáles de estos son consistentes
en general estudiantes que no estuvieron
obtuvieron calificaciones alrededor de
15 en el examen veamos esta no es verdad
porque vemos que estas personas que no
estuvieron nada no obtuvieron 15 en el
examen y esto definitivamente no es lo
que este 15 implica no dice lo que la
gente que no estudió obtuvo por lo que
esta no es verdadera
esa no es verdadera tratemos ahora está
si un estudiante estudió por una hora
más que otro estudiante el estudiante
que estudió más obtuvo exactamente 15
puntos más en su examen bueno está se
está aproximando a la esencia del
significado de la pendiente pero la
palabra exactamente es lo que bueno por
lo menos en mi mente desordena esta
opción porque sería ilógico que esté
garantizado que si estudias una hora
extra obtendrás 15% más en el examen
esto sólo dice que esta es la tendencia
general lo que se ve en esta línea no
está garantizado
por ejemplo veamos que este estudiante
de aquí estudió dos horas exactamente y
si vemos a los estudiantes que
estudiaron por tres horas bueno no hay
nadie exactamente en tres horas pero
algunos de ellos veamos este estudio dos
horas este como tres horas no hay nadie
exactamente allí pero nadie habrá
estudiantes que lo harán mejor que lo
esperado y estudiantes que lo harán un
poco peor
vean hay puntos por arriba de la línea
de tendencia y por abajo de la línea de
tendencia por lo que este exactamente no
puedes decir que está garantizado que
una hora incrementa un 15% así que
probemos con esta otra opción en general
estudiar para una hora extra está
asociado con 15 puntos de mejora en las
calificaciones del examen eso parece
correcto veamos esta última en general
estudiar por 15 horas extras está
asociado con un punto de mejora en la
calificación del examen eso que varía la
pendiente justo
en la otra dirección así que
definitivamente ese no es el caso así
que comprobemos la respuesta la tenemos
bien